[Music]
hey everybody happy tuesday or whatever
the hell day it is you can already see
in the comment section that this was a
polarizing movie
that was the impression i got like i
said this is one of those movies i i
never i try to never like watch any
reviews of stuff before i see it but
i'll watch reviews afterward because i'm
kind of interested to see like what yeah
this seems to be one of those movies
that people either like they love it or
they hate it
um
i well i'm kind of like fell in the
middle i actually enjoyed this
um but
and it's gonna be really really hard to
talk about it without spoiling it
i will say that the trailer
is a little bit misleading
it's not exactly because if you're
expecting like
the conjuring james one like because
from the trailer i kind of feel like
from what i can remember i saw the
trailer a couple of times
i feel like the trailer made it seem
more like uh you know kind of like a
trademark james wand type supernatural
ghost story possession type of thing
and
this is not it's kind of like that but
then it goes off in a different
direction which i would almost call
is this a spoiler it because essentially
like an action horror or or even a
slasher movie yeah um so i kind of feel
like this is more like dead silence type
james juan rather than the conjuring
james one yeah i had totally forgotten
that james wan also directed aquaman did
he yeah he did okay i liked the movie um
i was kind of sleepy when i went in
there
and um it felt very samey the first
20 minutes yeah it seemed like a james
juan ghost story yeah yeah so i started
to kind of drift off a little bit you
know
and uh then all of a sudden it
it started to get more interesting it
[ __ ] changed on me wait a minute hold
on this isn't a ghost movie you know
what i mean it's not like a
i thought it was about a ghost
and uh nah as it as it turns out it's
not and uh not really no
it's some pretty cool [ __ ] [ __ ]
happens in it
and uh i don't know
how you feel about this movie like i
said it's really really hard to talk
about uh because we actually i think
this is streaming on hbo max uh also
like for a month or whatever but it's
obviously playing in the theater it
started on friday so we went to the
theater and saw it yesterday afternoon
and
it's straight okay so i think what james
wan was going for and i think he was
sort of successful but how you feel
about this movie is
okay
so the very first scene of this he he
said he was going for almost like a
a giallo or like a brian de palma type
vibe
and
now that he said that like i can i kind
of see it
but i'm not sure like the tone of it was
a little uneven
because like the opening scene yeah is
kind of like a cheesy over-the-top
80s movie 80s movie like a throwback
sort of although i have seen people say
it's not even necessarily a throwback to
the 80s it's more like a throwback to
like the early 2000s yeah which like i
said this is much more like
dead silence than like james wan's newer
movie it looks it looked really cheap at
first yeah like it looked like the
acting was like deliberately over the
top so it seemed like a deliberate
choice yeah um you know just thinking
like asylum pictures almost like that
cheap at first
but it got better as it went a lot i it
drew me into it just because it started
to get [ __ ]
audacious you know what i mean i was
like yeah this is definitely one of
those movies and i've seen like this on
a couple of horror channels where people
like what the [ __ ] did i just watch well
just because it's because this movie is
it goes in like uh it becomes kind of
ridiculous
and how you how you feel about the
ridiculousness is how you're gonna feel
about like i said it's almost kind of
like you could see that he was trying to
do like an over the top
he said he was trying to do like a brian
de palma like campy
over the top and
i can see that but the weird thing about
it is that so the opening scene is kind
of like that like it's over the top like
80s
uh you know everyone's kind of
overacting and it's like the lights real
dramatic and everything and i was just
like okay i'm on board with this
whatever
but then it goes into your stock james
wan
ghost story possession type you know
what i mean you have this and you have
the kind of a character drama you have a
dream yeah you have like the main
character maddie who is pregnant and
she's had a few miscarriages and then
she's like with in this relationship
with this douche bag and he waxes like
he beats her up and everything like that
and then it seems like
um a ghost or something is like in their
house so like
so for that first
part of it it's almost kind of like
like you said like a sami james wand
type of movie just like some one of the
conjuring universe movies because
there's like a creepy
shadow ghosty thing and it's like you
think so you think it's like a ghost but
then as it goes on it goes in a little
bit of another direction and
okay so like i said
i can't say it was kind of like a batman
super villain
almost i was gonna say
somebody just said in the comments what
i was just about to
like i wasn't going to say it but i was
going to dance around it because i said
if i say
that it reminds me of a certain
low-budget movie from the 1980s yeah
everybody will know what the twist is
and i feel like this is better
if you don't know where it's going
although although you can maybe call it
in a way also this is very much like a
certain stephen king novel uh which i
also will not name because if i name it
then everybody that everybody will know
exactly what i'm talking about
is this move let's get down to breast
head
is this movie worth cost of admission
i'd say right now
yeah
yeah if you wanted to see a [ __ ]
badass action horror movie
that was kind of a throwback
to the 80s and 90s but with the [ __ ]
more modern technology and twist and
then yeah
it's it's a low budget
horror action flick
that did give you what you wanted
all right it even
set up the sequel they even set up the
secret because you knew that was going
to come as you're watching it you're
going like you know there's going to be
a sequel to this [ __ ]
because it's going down all those same
tropes and yeah they could set up a
sequel for that [ __ ]
and would you see the sequel after
seeing this
yeah yeah you probably would
i'd see the sequel like i said i can see
okay like i said how you feel about this
movie is gonna be how much patience do
you have for
how ridiculous it goes it's very
audacious like you said it's audacious
um and it's almost kind of like i can
see the [ __ ] with you i can see that
james juan was kind of like right out
the gate because like i said the opening
credits
seem like a two early 2000s horror movie
like the imagery is very early 2000s and
then it goes into a you know a cold
opener like an opening sequence which is
very
over the top yeah um you know with even
like you're not sure and i wasn't sure
if like the acting was like deliberately
cheesy and i'm guessing that's probably
what he was going for but then it kind
of threw me off because it then it goes
into a very serious
ghost type movie like the conjuring uh
where there's like family drama and
stuff
but then as it goes on it starts getting
like weirder and weirder and weirder
yeah and then it like you said it goes
into like full on like action
type
movie
and he was kind of it seemed like he was
almost trying to do like a giallo thing
too like with the with the
killer and with the coat and the gloves
everything he was doing he was trying to
give you a good bang for your buck
to give the audience what you wanted
uh it was gonna have it was gonna be
like a really good
low budget cheesy horror action flick
that that's the vibe that he wanted but
he wanted it to have quality and it did
he i think he did it it is it's not a
low quality movie
it's a high quality movie because i was
entertained and it looked good it got
better looking as it went it opened up
with some real almost looked like asylum
pictures
it did well because that's why i was
kind of like well at first yeah i was
kind of like well is this on purpose i
said if it's on purpose then okay i'm on
board because if you're going to make a
ridiculous movie just lean into it just
as i've said before but then it started
to get kind of serious like and then and
then i was like damn codring or
something and then i was like well made
then maybe it wasn't deliberate yeah but
i think maybe he did do that
deliberately just to like lull you into
it it's okay it's it's just a regular
ass james wan movie but oh now we're
gonna go [ __ ] crazy and michael e
just said exactly i think i said this
earlier on uh it wasn't anything like i
expected based on the trailer i was
getting a paranormal activity vibe from
the trailer yeah it was kind of like the
trailer made it look like kind of a
patented uh james wong type movie i did
he wanted you to think too yeah and i
think he did that deliberately because
he's like oh no wait a minute i'm going
to make like this totally crazy now i
will say like one criticism i have is
that that real big like action set piece
at the like in the police station like i
said it's not a spoiler uh it happens at
a police station that looked a little
bit like a video game cut scene yeah
it's okay um but so this yeah so did the
beginning the castle that's true that
looked like a video game cut scene and
it looked like asylum pictures but you
know what i was just so castro with it
let's see what's going to happen and it
delivered it delivered
it's got a good monster
good action scenes for the monster
you're like what the [ __ ] am i looking
at
and it's all in the in and it was
[ __ ] with me the whole time and then
it started revealing and unveiling more
and like oh okay
and then
it's just uh i don't want to spoil it
you know what i mean because
this would be a good experience in the
theater especially if if you don't take
it seriously
that's the thing yeah don't and and like
i'm saying have a good time don't
okay that's all i'm gonna say is that
the trailer is not exactly the type of
movie so it might not be the type of
movie that you think
it is yeah that's all i'm going to say
um like i said it's really michael e
said
said a movie in the comments in the in
the chat that i was thinking of like
when i saw this movie and i was kind of
like oh i got you you're going in that
direction but like i said i don't really
want to say it out loud okay that was
named that
that studio that did that movie i know
what you want to talk about what was the
name of the studio
uh
i don't know the studio that did the
movie that was mentioned in the comment
section
i don't i don't remember the oh okay the
studio it wasn't okay it wasn't enough i
didn't see it then we're talking about a
different one having to do with the
[ __ ] now you say no yeah i don't want
to spoil it we did a review of it not
too long
not too long ago but didn't that
director make a bunch of those kind of
movies
yeah yeah okay yeah i thought it
it's a director it's not so much that
yeah yeah yeah but i'm not going to say
that okay because it's giving away too
much because it's given because if i say
then everybody will know exactly just
like if i say what stephen king's story
it reminded me of yeah what stephen king
novel it reminded me of then people if
you remember like what happened in that
story then you'll know i could tell that
he's where he tried to be a hundred
percent original he's using a bunch of
tropes and [ __ ] that worked in the past
but it's an original amalgamation of all
this stuff it's an original application
and
he's trying to reboot
the horror this type of horror movie
for a new generation and trying to
refresh in the genre
it feels like an 80s movie internet or a
night it feels like in parts yeah or a
mid 90s movie this kind of reminded me
that one arnold schwarzenegger movie in
a certain way what was the one where he
damn
[ __ ] the devil's girlfriend and beat the
devil what was the name
uh
right before 2 000. um end of days into
days there's something about
not really but
something about the tone kind of
reminded me of towards the end you know
it became an action movie yeah it kind
of took me into the end of days type
or or or i don't know
i don't know why that came to mind
yeah it's a like i said it's a hard it's
a hard movie to talk about because you
can't say it's like freddy krueger movie
no you can't say it's like
friday the 13th no so what is it like it
is its own thing
i liked it
there are the only other movies of the
[ __ ] one that we're talking about and
and uh the stephen king stephen king
concept yeah like it's not it's not a
completely unique concept because i've
seen it done before or similar this also
would have made a good batman super
villain
this character this this this monster
that had made a good song about a batman
it might be that's a little might have
been a little too r r-rated for batman
i mean i don't know i don't know if
james wan like i i don't i think he just
wanted to do this as like a one-off i
don't know if he's gonna planning on
making a whole franchise out of it
because everything's got to be a [ __ ]
franchise well definitely he set it up
for he set that up for uh
oh yeah it totally it totally could yeah
and it's not just a a villain or a
monster there is some paranormal [ __ ]
that it can do so it's not
a hundred percent natural explanation
you know what i mean the thing can do
things with its mind
um it can do weird things with his
[ __ ] body
and uh
it's also based on some old stories of
the eighteen hundreds of [ __ ]
certain [ __ ] dudes that evidently
existed
freaks and [ __ ] it's it's weird it's
kind of like a freaking nature type
thing
yeah which like i said it kind of
i don't know i i liked this movie i
enjoyed it but it's like i think at
first it kind of threw me off because
the tonal whiplash between the opening
scene and then what it was like and then
what it was like for like the next act
and a half like the next half an hour
i'm just kind of like yeah this is so
weird like
the well the first part the first scene
yeah i almost thought
that
is this going to be like a movie within
a movie like we're going to pull back
and like the characters are watching
this movie right and it's weird because
i thought that when i was watching the
movie and then i was watching another
review of it and somebody else said the
exact same thing yeah that like that
opening scene they almost thought it was
so cheesy that it was like yeah it
starts off with a [ __ ] mental asylum
that's almost like a castle it reminded
me of something like out of batman's
arkham asylum
yeah
and that's why i think it kind of
reminded me of an escaped batman [ __ ]
villain type of deal
with a paranormal element
but it all kind of worked out yeah there
was some kind of weird tunnel shifts but
it probably wouldn't seem as bad if we
saw it again a second time well yeah and
i mean like i said it's not i think that
it and it's kind of on purpose i think i
think he did it on purpose i think that
he was trying to deceive you as
well i mean they definitely were with
the trailer because the trailer seemed
almost like to me the trailer looked
like um she was like they i think in the
trailer they had like that cool effect
where she's sitting there and then it's
like a 360 and then like the the room
like morphs into another room
um so they almost kind of made it look
like a psychic
type of stuff like she had a psychic
link with a killer type of thing or she
was seeing murders and i think like the
only description of this movie was like
she
she sees murders or she has visions of
them and then turns out that they really
happened which does happen in the movie
but that description is also a little
bit uh deceiving and the trailer was for
sure deceiving the trailer looked like
um like a standard james wand movie
about a woman who is psychically seeing
all these murders happen and that's not
exactly how it ends up going yeah but i
kind of feel like there's been a lot of
that lately where
which in a way i can see because they
don't want like people don't want their
movies spoiled they want people to go
into a movie with people in there spoil
it
you got people that want to see it we uh
we saw it in the theater we got we got
amc
uh a list yeah um i don't know if it's
live streaming it's on hbo max hbo max
okay it was good in the theater
uh
i don't know what it's like to see it on
[ __ ] you know if you if your system's
good it'll be good um it is different
but if you're our age group you will
understand a lot of what it's doing
yeah maybe that's why i kind of feel
like the one girl like the the horror
girl that i watch i can't remember what
her name is but um that really hated
this movie she's much younger yeah and
she's way more into uh like newer movies
like like 2000s type movies
um whereas this movie
fallback slash reboot it's a little bit
of a throwback but in a weird kind of
way it's like not not not a throwback in
the same way that because you know
there's movies lately like you know
house of the devil or yeah well that's
not that way but
but but that was made to look like a
movie from back then
but this one not so much i think he like
he's homaging like i said like cheesy
over the top 80s 90s brian de palma type
[ __ ] like campy
but also mixing it in with something
that is kind of like a standard james
wand movie so that you're sort of like
thrown off like because the tone is very
strange visually it was shot real well
quality was good
uh character design costume was good um
uh casting is good uh score and sound
effects were very good i liked it i
liked it um i actually really liked the
score for this it's kind of over the top
and then it you know like really like
over dramatic which opening scene is
seen through like a 80s videotaped
camera but it's not quite done it looks
like a cgi cut screen like she was
talking about
the the establishing shots it's like
arkham asylum it's almost like a video
game it's like something out of a damn
an asylum film which there's a couple of
asylum movies that i like but it seems
real low budget but then it goes into a
thing the budget starts getting a little
higher and higher as it goes then it
goes into something kind of like a
conjuring universe for a little while i
started to kind of nod out like yeah
this is kind of save me and then boom it
took a turn
what the [ __ ] is this and then it's an
action movie
i liked it i liked it because it it was
definitely trying to
the tonal shift is definitely trying to
uh
to deceive you well
it was and in the context of the story
now that i'm thinking about it in the
context of the story which i can't spoil
like how like how it plays out
it actually makes sense yeah but if you
don't know
how it's gonna end or how it ends up
then it might seem like the tone is like
all over the place they're trying to
establish uh heroes and villains in kind
of uh the same way they used to do it in
the 80s and 90s when they'd start a
franchise they're trying to establish a
uh a monster slash villain along the
lines of freddy krueger and jason and
and you know michael myers they're
trying to have they're trying to give
you a
recognizable individual bad guy and it
is a good concept it is a good concept i
liked it yeah yeah i liked the concept
behind that yeah i would watch another
one like i said especially if it was
audacious if the second one did some
more audacious [ __ ]
then uh like there's more of these
things or there's things that are kind
of like a different version of that or
you know
then you might get the spirit world
involved or psychic abilities involved
let's involve the spirit world yeah you
don't know what well you could you could
take this some [ __ ] crazy places
and if it was done right then yeah it
would be successful
yeah i mean i definitely would like i
said you know i'm not if people hate it
because i know dj maniac said this movie
[ __ ] show yeah and it's supposed to be a
[ __ ] show and i get that like you know
your patience for ridiculousness is
gonna really like that's a good gauge of
how you're gonna feel about this movie
because
like you said it's ridiculous but i
think in a lot of ways it's ridiculous
on purpose yeah um so it wasn't like an
accident but i but even at first
having seen most of james wan's other
movies
um i wasn't sure at first if it was i
was like
just particularly that opening scene i
was like wait is this just bad acting or
is this
no they're going or is this like
supposed to be like a cheesy movie
within a movie that the characters are
watching
or
like i couldn't tell i couldn't quite
tell if it was deliberate but then as it
went on i was like okay i guess it is
deliberate like once we got into the
third act i was like okay well i guess
he knew what he was doing yeah um but
i can see how maybe that wouldn't work
for some people yeah some of the
supporting casts are kind of cartoonish
yeah it's supposed to be that way yeah
it's kind of like why i was saying like
this is almost like something out of a
[ __ ] dc universe video game of batman
or something yeah like one of the
[ __ ] villains
and it's funny because you have arkham
asylum something out of arkham yeah it
does have that kind of vibe to it yeah
it's funny and i had totally forgotten
until i was you know kind of watching
other reviews of this that james wan had
done aquaman because i think one of the
things we liked about aquaman was that
it was it was ridiculous yeah but it
leaned into the ridiculousness imagine
if somebody tried to do
venom which is a movie about a [ __ ]
bad guy you know what i mean but they
tried to do it
in like the batman universe
it's kind of like arkham asylum and this
is like
the the origin story of a super villain
and it's
it's and it's the main character
eventually
that might be kind of the way he meant
it this i think this might have been
kind of like a super villain movie
yeah i could see that
because if he did
aquaman then he would know
and i mean if he felt like a v like a
like a batman video game
from the nine from the two you know yeah
like arkham asylum batman arkham asylum
type it did have that it did have that
vibe to it but only only like in the
third act yeah like only in like the
second half or like at the very
beginning and then the [ __ ] in the
very very beginning and then like and
then there's a tunnel shift into
something like out of the conjuring
universe but then it went nope that's
not what movie this is it's this and
then you're like oh we're doing this
okay all right
[Laughter]
but you know he's [ __ ] with you it's
okay
which yeah i just respect that i enjoy
it and honestly i'm glad to see him
coming back to horror even though and
i've mentioned this before
um i'm not like i liked the first
conjuring movie um the other ones were
just all right because i definitely feel
like james wan he didn't direct all the
conjuring but i think he just did the
first two um and then he farmed it out
to other people but i definitely feel
like james wan has a has a brand
and he has like a formula that he works
with so this one like seemed like it
shook that up a little bit it did remind
me of like his earlier [ __ ] like dead
silence
which i didn't love but it has that kind
of cheesy tone to it so i was laughing
at like injustice for me says insidious
malignant up next cantankerous
i would totally watch a movie called
cantankerous or vetuperative yeah
herself
in a bad mood
[Laughter]
what do you mean i'm always in a bad
mood
you know that
uh yeah so somebody else said um
uh beastnow said i don't watch a lot of
modern movies
uh and then louie asked if you prefer
the classics and uh he said
you know
well i lost it okay maybe he maybe so
but he said mostly he just like watched
old stuff honestly it's like i like
movies from all i mean i've seen some
new ones that were that were really
really good that were great that i loved
um
but i mean most of my favorite ones tend
to be older but that's just because one
i grew up with them two i've seen them a
bunch of times so i can appreciate them
more um who's to say like one that came
out recently if i see it more times in
the future that'll become like one of my
favorite movies you know and i brought
this up before but something like
hereditary which just came out of 2018
um you know easily one of my favorite
horror movies ever
um so i so i don't like wanna [ __ ] on
modern movies because there's good [ __ ]
coming out all the time it's just it a
lot of times it just has to have time to
yeah especially this one probably
there's a there i think there's a good
potential for multiple viewings i think
if i saw it again i might like it even
more
yeah because the first time you go into
it like like i said i was kind of unsure
because i was like this seems like it's
sort of all over the place
um
but now that i'm thinking about it and i
was like thinking about what he was
trying to do and how the story went and
like
you know just from a meta point of view
like he he wanted to like the approach
he was taking i feel like if we watched
it a second time you might like it
better because you knew what was coming
so it's not gonna you're not gonna be
like finding your feet the whole time
like wait what is this what is happening
now supposed to be a really good fun
cheap low budget [ __ ]
horror movie i don't know if it was
horrib
low budget it probably cost a lot of
money to make but that was the motif
behind it well by this
i think they i mean it's you don't
usually see horror movies that are super
super high budget i mean even nowadays
um
shots thrown in the third act look real
good yeah some of those action scenes
were although like i said that one shot
the one scene like the kind of iconic
one in the in the police station did
look a little bit
cgi-e yeah i thought like a video game
but i was having fun with it i wasn't uh
you know what i mean yeah i was too but
i'm just saying that some people don't
really care some people might get like
faces and stuff looked [ __ ] kind of
fake but i didn't care i was enjoying it
yeah because it's funny because
audacious and [ __ ] because you were you
were thinking that like the first part
that was going on that was just about
maddie and like maybe she's seeing these
murders and it's like a psychic thing
and you said after you said yeah i
thought it was kind of boring and i was
like falling asleep but then it goes in
this other direction you're like all
right i'm now i'm on board you know
yeah
now i'm on board
it fooled me it deceived me
and like i said
yeah because obviously they should know
what it is they were trying to fool
everybody with the trailer because the
trailer is not really what the movie is
like would i pay money to stream this
yeah
yeah yeah would i go to the movie
theater and pay to see it yeah yeah
although we saw it for we saw it on
you know for the price of seeing two
movies a month at least you just get a
list
yeah yeah because honestly you can see
three movies a week
and
even if you see two or three movies a
month that still pays for it because it
only costs what like twenty something
two dollars twenty four twenty four
bucks to get a reserve seat
in any movie at any time and you can see
twelve mo twelve movies a month for 25
bucks you can't beat it which is super
that includes all the [ __ ] dolby
dolby theater ones and we like to go
during the matinee when it's kind of
dead um
but you know it doesn't cover any
special stuff like you know if if
something is fathom events you have to
pay separate for those like when we go
to rifftrax live just because that's an
outside company that just rents out amc
um but anything honestly i'm pretty sure
they're showing labyrinth on the big
screen because i saw it when i was
leaving and it's like i might be able to
get that for free i think for a hundred
bucks you can actually rent the theater
to show whatever movie you want
to yeah you might be able to
now i don't know if you get ticket
proceeds of somebody else i don't know
if you can make that a public event and
make money if people come to see it i
doubt it they should have set that [ __ ]
up like that
to where okay i'm gonna play this movie
i'm gonna pay the hundred bucks and open
it to the general public and and i get
the t you know some of the [ __ ]
public showing of getting cash is
haunted starting belladonna no i'd
probably
sorry that's just my favorite porn movie
title so i have to keep bringing it up i
would probably do like something out of
the aliens or predator predator one see
how many people showed up to that well
like i said they have been showing like
old movies they're doing labyrinth
either i think they're doing it now
because i think i saw it like up on the
little marquee thing when we were
leaving yeah and i was kind of like oh i
wouldn't mind seeing that on the big
screen i think i did actually see that
on the big screen when i was a kid
because i think that came out when i was
14 i want to say
but um so i think i did see that in the
theater back in the day but i'm sure
it's probably been like re uh whatever
that word is yeah remastered because i
can't remember words anymore apparently
um but yeah so
yeah this is
i can definitely see why this movie is
polarizing because if you're going into
it expecting one thing and then you're
just like what the [ __ ] is this even
that i'm watching um then
maybe you're not gonna be able to get
over that but
i don't know i had a good time with it
although i think i kind of had the same
reaction as you did the you know the
opening scene i was kind of like okay
this is like super cheesy um
but i'm on board that's fine um but then
it went into like a more standard
type conjuring universe type movie and
then i was like all right this is okay
you know but this is kind of like all
the other ones but then when it kind of
like took like a hard left turn or
whatever yeah i don't know if i call it
that but it it does like go in a
different direction and then i was just
kind of like oh all right okay all right
yeah and it's like it's pretty uh it's
pretty gory too yeah although it's not
like super there's like a lot of
stabbing like facial stabbings and a lot
of like bones breaking kind of like
somebody takes an arm and goes and like
the bone comes out like so it's pretty
gory um so you know if you're into that
but you probably have to wait till you
get to the end but you'd like lots of
limbs being broken and necks being
turned around and whatnot but you know
uh and justice for me said do you
remember the dark crystal yes i do i
tried to watch that recently couldn't
get through it again i mean the puppets
are amazing but i like labyrinth a lot
better like story what um dark crystal
is great like i love the look of it but
the story of it is a little slow
a little ponderous whereas labyrinth is
a lot like faster moving right
and yeah dark crystal was great when
you're a kid but it didn't i tried to
get to it like 20 minutes into it's like
this is unwatchable and just like it had
edited
i kind of liked the series that they did
um but i don't think i ever finished
watching it i think i watched like the
first few episodes i'm like oh this is
good i should finish this up one day but
then i kind of think i kind of forgot
about it well you know oh well um but
yeah so i guess like i said we can't say
too much more without spoiling it yeah
um
we did a good job let's pat ourselves on
the back how about that well there's not
more we can say about it right yeah
that's true yeah but like i said it's
just keep in mind it's it's going to be
a polarizing movie so i hesitate to
recommend it because i'm just drink
yeah i hesitate to recommend it because
then people be mad at me if they go see
it and be like that was the worst [ __ ]
ever you know what i mean um because i
can see like it's not the worst [ __ ]
ever it's not but you know how people
yeah you know how people overreact to
everything and it's like everything it's
worse than cancer oh my god it's like
that kind of because it's the internet
that's just how it is yeah but um you
know so it's just a [ __ ] show it's
supposed to be a [ __ ] show it [ __ ]
does all kinds of [ __ ] audacious [ __ ]
yeah like all right all right just know
that it's not the type of movie that you
think it's gonna be yeah that's all i'm
saying like from the trailer it's it's
deceptive
um but i enjoyed it i thought it was fun
yeah
it's just entertainment yeah it was just
i thought it was kind of entertaining uh
but yeah so it's tuesday right so
tomorrow is the side tracks
drinking show yeah so we'll probably be
talking about we probably got to get
some more booze tomorrow
probably be talking about all kinds of
crap talking about moving planes
all that kind of stuff
in case you guys didn't hear about it
we'll probably go into it more on uh
yeah we'll talk about tomorrow tomorrow
night because it all worked out good we
mentioned it on sunday but in case like
some people weren't going to a bigger
house yeah we'll see we'll see how it's
all going to go i'm excited but yeah so
uh thanks everybody for dropping by
today talking about james wan's new
malignant and we will see you guys
tomorrow at 5 p.m eastern standard time
see you then
bye